[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
japón tiene una relación con sus vecinos
de sergeant a algún tanto especial por
no decir complicada o incluso tormentosa
aquí en visual políticos hemos hablado
de ello en varias ocasiones y la razón
común siempre suele ser la misma las
rencillas históricas que una y otra y
otra vez retornan como un boomerang a la
actualidad política pero como siempre
ocurre existen excepciones en concreto
hay un país que también sufrió el pasado
colonial de japón pero que sin embargo
tiene unas relaciones muy buenas con el
país del sol naciente dos países que
están forjando una estrecha alianza con
importantes implicaciones para toda la
región una alianza no solo en el terreno
económico donde al final más o menos
todo se entienden sino también el
aspecto político y ojo porque
sorprendentemente hablamos de taiwán
[Música]
y digo sorprendentemente porque no
podemos olvidar que detrás de todo ojo
avizor está china para el gigante
asiático cualquier cosa que tenga que
ver con taiwán se convierte en todo un
agravio o una amenaza para la seguridad
nacional y claro china es hoy por hoy el
mayor cliente de la economía nipona las
empresas japonesas para que os hagáis
una idea tienen invertidos más de 130
mil millones de dólares en inversión
extranjera en la república popular y los
chinos suponen casi el 30 por ciento de
todos los turistas que cada año visita
en el país del sol naciente así que no
sé a priori eso de arriesgarse a sacar
de sus casillas al gigante asiático pues
qué queréis que os diga no parece una
buena idea pero entonces que un
exactamente a japon con taiwán que ha
llevado a tokio a querer aproximarse
tanto a taipei que están buscando
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas y si tal y como muchos os
estaréis imaginando en toda esta
historia tiene mucha influencia la
creciente agenda nacionalista de xi
jinping pero eso eso no es todo los
crecientes vínculos entre japón y taiwán
no se definen únicamente por tener un
adversario común sino que en cierto modo
hablamos de una alianza asentada en
cuestiones económicas sociales e incluso
para bien o para mal en una historia
compartida
[Música]
taiwán comparte con la china continental
la reclamación sobre las islas senkaku
administradas actualmente por el país
del sol naciente pese a ello en la
política exterior entre taiwán y japón
no existe resquicios de hostilidad todo
lo contrario taiwán que fue también
ocupada y colonizada por el imperio de
japón una de las pocas colonias sino la
única donde apenas hubo resistencia
interna a la ocupación de hecho
probablemente fue también el territorio
ocupado con mayor cantidad de
colaboracionistas con los japoneses y
todavía a día de hoy mucha gente en
taiwán tiene un recuerdo dulce de la
colonización un periodo en el que te
igual logró convertirse en el territorio
más rico de toda asia oriental si es
templo amos claro está al propio japón
por ejemplo durante ese período se
multiplicaron por 10 sus kilómetros de
líneas de ferrocarril y los japoneses
desarrollaron una destacada potencia
eléctrica la isla para potenciar su
industria textil y química y gracias en
buena medida a ello y wang comenzó su
industrialización mucho antes que la
mayor parte del resto de países
asiáticos de tal forma que la industria
taiwanesa experimentó un importante
desarrollo durante la primera mitad del
siglo 20 aunque luego la segunda guerra
mundial supuso que la mayor parte de la
herencia japonesa se perdiera por
completo
[Música]
además se puede decir que a pesar de la
fuerte represión a la disidencia
política a las torturas y las
ejecuciones sumarísimas que siempre
caracterizaba al imperio japonés taiwán
fue la niña animada de entre todas las
colonias
y el caso es que toda esta historia
compartida explica en buena medida que
taiwán oficialmente la república de
china tuviera muchas menos dificultades
para establecer relaciones diplomáticas
amistosas con el japón de la posguerra
unas relaciones que han unido estos dos
países en una especie de simbiosis tan
acusada y para muchos de ewan es como
una especie de hermana china de japón
pero qué intereses unen hoy por hoy a
japón con taiwán hacia donde están
avanzando las relaciones entre ambos
países habrá cambios en las políticas de
japón hacia china en favor de taiwán
pues atentos
[Música]
la amistad japón taiwán interés mutuo
sobre el mapa pueden parecernos muy
lejanos pero lo cierto es que a menos de
110 kilómetros de distancia se encuentra
el punto más cercano entre japón y
taiwán estoy hablando en concreto de la
isla de yonaguni y luego un poquito más
lejos a unos 220 km y está la isla de
ishigaki donde japón está pensando en
construir la base militar más próxima a
la china comunista si lo habéis
escuchado bien japón ha decidido
construir su base militar más cercana a
la china continental una base situada
poco más de 200 kilómetros de taiwán
toda una carta de intenciones os
imagináis que japón habría decidido
montar una base militar tan cerca de
corea del sur en la que se hubiera
aliado luego hablaremos de este tema con
más detalle el caso amigos es que los
taiwaneses lejos de enfadarse o sentirse
amenazados están encantados seguro
seguro que todos os imaginéis porque con
todo sigue siendo llamativo que japón
está haciendo semejante gesto y para los
que os lo preguntéis no japón tampoco
reconoce oficialmente a taiwán junio de
2021 japón dice que los lazos con taiwán
son solo no oficiales claro que eso no
ha sido obstáculo para que desde que
japón dejará de reconocer oficialmente
al gobierno de formosa los lazos entre
ambos territorios no hayan hecho más que
crecer y crecer
[Música]
en 1972 japón dejó de reconocer
formalmente a la república de china que
es como se llama oficialmente taiwán
para pasar a reconocer a la república
popular china como el gobierno legítimo
de toda china sin embargo estos niños
hacia la china comunista que estaba
llevando a cabo la mayor parte de los
países del mundo en realidad no tuvieron
ninguna consecuencia sobre el terreno
las empresas japonesas siguieron
deslocalizando producción hacia taiwán
aprovechándose de la mano de obra
relativamente más barata y logró un
posicionamiento muy importante en su
tejido industrial y no sólo eso japón
también estuvo presente en taiwán como
uno de los principales inversores
durante la transformación industrial que
experimentó a taiwán en los años 70
taiwán paso de las fábricas textiles a
las petroquímicas y en la década de los
80 y 90 logró desarrollar una potente
industria y en especial de hardware y
muy concretamente de semiconductores en
todos estos casos el capital japonés fue
decisivo
y curiosamente en este último campo
taiwán ha logrado ganarle con holgura
japón es el país de formosa el que ahora
lleva la delantera hasta el punto de que
podría darse el escenario contrario al
que históricamente se dio la
deslocalización industrial de taiwán a
japón es ms valor abrir en japón una
fábrica de chips en 2023 para surtir a
sonny para los que no lo sepáis test mc
es el mayor y más avanzado fabricante de
semiconductores de todo el mundo y si es
taiwanés
[Música]
los semiconductores amigos son la clave
el eje central el corazón y el cerebro
de las nuevas tecnologías la robótica la
nueva tecnología la conducción autónoma
el 5g los sistemas militares más
modernos etcétera etcétera todo
absolutamente todo depende de los
semiconductores y aquí está igual es el
gran líder mundial y claro si no quieres
dejar que china se convierta en el líder
único indiscutible de la región la
tecnología juega un papel clave en este
aspecto una mayor integración económica
entre japón y taiwán podría tener
enormes ventajas geoeconómicas juntos
ambos países estarían muy bien
posicionados para liderar la carrera
tecnológica en asia-pacífico con todo lo
que ello implica y ojo porque esto puede
resultar clave para el futuro de la
región y sobre todo para el papel de
eeuu en esta zona no vamos a negar que
tanto japón como taiwán son grandes
aliados de washington así que dicho y
hecho la integración ambos países es
cada vez mayor otro ejemplo lo tenemos
en materia de infraestructuras a
principios de 2007 se puso en servicio
el primer ferrocarril de alta velocidad
de taiwán y tanto sus trenes como su
redes y tecnología fueron directamente
importados de japón
de hecho los trenes utilizados para la
línea de alta velocidad del modelo de
hsr 700t que son fabricados por un
consorcio entre empresas filiales de
kawasaki hitachi y nipón sario son una
versión adaptada de los shinkansen
japoneses por cierto apunte esta fue la
primera vez que japón exportó su
tecnología de alta velocidad a un país
extranjero y como veis el hecho de que
sea precisamente a taiwán no fue ni
mucho menos una casualidad la obra fue
de una complejidad tan grande que por si
mismo tendría espacio mega project para
que os hagáis una idea se construyó el
cien por cien desde cero y el 70 por
ciento del recorrido discurre por
viaductos taiwán invirtió 16 mil 500
millones de dólares en esa línea eso sí
el 79 por ciento fue sufragado por la
inversión privada y muy importante tomar
notas políticos derrochadores del mundo
esta línea es una de las pocas líneas de
alta velocidad en todo el planeta que
son rentables más de 8 mil millones de
dólares de taiwán de beneficio neto en
2019 unos 300 millones de dólares
americanos pero esto momento porque
evidentemente hay más mucho más en
materia de defensa y geopolítica es
donde la relación entre estos dos países
alcanza realmente su culmen una unión
tan fuerte como informal pero sólida al
fin y al cabo y es que amigos japón
tiene importantes planes para que igual
o quizás para sí mismo pero da igual
porque benefician directamente a la isla
reclamada por china atentos
el plan y sigue aquí
[Música]
fijaos un momento en este mapa
se trata de la cadena de islas ryükyü
las islas más occidentales de japón
entre las cuales hay una que tenemos que
destacar en este vídeo y siga aquí
[Música]
además de ser uno de los principales
destinos turísticos de la prefectura de
okinawa al margen de la propia isla de
okinawa ishigaki es también una isla
estratégica para japón situado a un paso
de taiwán y muy cerca de la china
continental pero lo suficientemente
lejos como para no estar excesivamente
expuesta y si llega aquí podría ser la
próxima fortaleza militar estratégica de
japón allí las fuerzas de auto defensa
niponas planean desplegar entre finales
de 2022 y marzo de 2023 tanto misiles
antibuque como misiles antiaéreos además
de un contingente de entre 500 y 600
soldados para operarlos todo esto con la
excusa la excusa de proteger las islas
senkaku diaoyu de las provocaciones
chinas
sin embargo la realidad podría ser
diferente el hecho de tener un
contingente militar está cerca de taiwán
ha sido visto por estos últimos como un
mensaje claro de protección al país
insular al tiempo que también protege al
propio japón y llegado el caso podría
ser incluso una base de operaciones para
los eeuu
plan de misiles de japón en ishigaki
ayuda a reforzar la defensa de taiwán
analistas dicen que el plan pretende
defender taiwán tanto como japón ya que
cualquier ataque en la isla democrática
podría rápidamente extenderse a las
islas japonesa sureñas la primera línea
defensiva de tokio vale y sigue aquí y
no será la primera de las islas ryükyü
vencer armadas con misiles de hecho
sería la cuarta pero es importante
porque es la más próxima china de entre
todas las islas que contarían con bases
de misiles niponas y no crees en por un
instante que este plan es nuevo
la idea de fortificar y siga aquí con
misiles viene barruntando se las cabezas
pensantes del gobierno japonés desde
2017 y claro ahora la cada vez más
agresiva campaña de provocaciones chinas
en el mar de la china oriental y en el
estrecho de taiwán han movido finalmente
al gobierno y por a dar el paso la idea
es crear una especie de muralla de islas
fortificadas con misiles capaces de
repeler una hipotética invasión china
contra las islas sur occidentales de
japón ahora bien pensarlo un momento si
un país que antiguamente te ha
colonizado anuncia que va a poner
misiles a pocos kilómetros de tus costas
lo normal sería protestar sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta los suspicaces que son
con la cuestión territorial en esta zona
del mundo no nos parece de hecho eso es
exactamente lo que haría cualquier otra
ex colonia nipona pues no en este caso
no puertas adentro las autoridades de
taiwán han celebrado este paso como toda
una victoria diplomática pero vale
además de él ya de por sí importante
plan para instalar misiles en irak y
todavía hay más
como ya os hemos contado en el boletín
semanal de patrón sorprendentemente y a
pesar de los crecientes tentáculos de
china-taiwán cada vez tiene más amigos a
lo largo y ancho del mundo y lo cierto
es que muchas potencias ya se mueven en
direcciones molestas para china como por
ejemplo pedir que taiwán sea incluido
como miembro de la ms que es exactamente
lo que se acordó en el ultimo g7 y luego
luego hay países concretos que están
teniendo más que gestos discretos con
taiwán obviamente hablamos de japón
fijaos japón elimina taiwán del mapa de
china en el libro blanco de defensa en
una advertencia china el nuevo libro
estratégico de japón menciona taiwan por
primera vez el vice ministro de defensa
de japón dice que taiwán debe ser
protegido como un país democrático sí
aunque pueda resultarnos increíble lo
cierto es que japón se está posicionando
como la única fuerza en la se orienta el
aparentemente dispuesta hacer frente a
china una posición que se podría
reforzar si finalmente el país nipón
cambia su constitución pacifista que lo
obliga a no intervenir en el extranjero
aunque eso todavía está por ver pero la
cosa tampoco acaba aquí
[Música]
muchos medios internacionales se han
hecho eco de un debate que está en el
seno del parlamento nipón una ley de
relaciones con taiwán propia y es que
veréis en concreto se toma como ejemplo
la ley de relaciones con taiwán aprobada
en 1979 por eeuu cuando el país pasó a
reconocer a la república popular china
en detrimento de la república de china
entre otras cosas la ley sirvió para
establecer fuertes relaciones no
oficiales incluso relaciones
prácticamente diplomáticas con una
embajada americana de facto una relación
especial reglada por ley algo de lo que
japón hoy por hoy carece además recordad
que esta ley estadounidense también
habla en términos de defensa en concreto
su sección 2.4 dice lo siguiente y es
política de los eeuu considerar
cualquier esfuerzo para determinar el
futuro de taiwán por medios que no sean
pacíficos incluidos boicots o embargos
una amenaza para la paz y la seguridad
del área del pacífico occidental y de
gran preocupación para los eeuu sección
2 b 4 de la ley de relaciones con taiwán
obviamente no sabemos y la idea de los
legisladores japoneses que presionan
para tramitar una ley similar a esta
incluye incorporar el campo de la
defensa militar a los boicots y
sanciones contra chinas pero lo que
desde luego si busca esta ley es
establecer una relación
más estrecha con taiwán en detrimento de
la china continental y eso es todo un
cambio en el tablero de juego con pekín
[Música]
juntos ambos países podrían convertirse
en la punta de lanza de una nueva ola
pro democrática en la región con los
recursos suficientes como para atraer a
otros países y contener el creciente
peso de china sobre todo si tenemos en
cuenta los lazos con eeuu y su peso
económico y tecnológico sin ir más lejos
la inversión combinada de ambos países
en i + d se aproxima a los 250 mil
millones de dólares anuales de momento
el primer gran cambio puede ser la
entrada de taiwán en el ppt pp el
heredero del acuerdo comercial
transpacífico un acuerdo al que tal y
como os contamos el reino unido ha
solicitado adherirse recientemente y que
está liderado precisamente por japonés
se establece una hoja de ruta para que
te igual según al cpp quien nos lo iba a
decir el pasivo japón comenzando a
liderar un aparente muro de contención a
las ambiciones de pekín claro que todo
esto abre otro debate puede japón
intensificar realmente sus relaciones
con taiwán sin poner en riesgo sus
enormes vínculos económicos con china
estamos tal vez ante el primer ejemplo
en asia de un discurso duro contra las
políticas nacionales imperialistas de xi
jinping ojo que no son preguntas menores
de hecho ese es precisamente el debate
tanto en japón como en los propios eeuu
mano dura contra xi jinping de momento
puedes dejarnos tu opinión aquí abajo en
los comentarios y ya sabes si este vídeo
te resultó interesante no olvides like y
suscribirte a visual político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]